it's not as if you have to pay people to
believe things that are wrong every time
someone says something that another
person disagrees with they'll go like
you're a grifter you're only saying that
because there a financial incentive as
if no one has ever been incorrect about
anything because they just came to the
wrong conclusion on their own it's like
sometimes people just believe things
that are wrong in fact it's crazy most
of the time people believe things that
are wrong right and you don't have to
believe that the federal government is
paying somebody the reality is we live
in a system where people are not
encouraged to choose virtue when you're
not encouraged to choose virtue you're
going to take the path of least
resistance as often as possible and that
means falling in line with opinions that
are more popular because it's difficult
to argue for unpopular opinions that's
all it is you don't have to fund anybody
you don't have to run any kind of like
Special Operation to get pop artists
like come on why does someone become
just think about it why does someone
become a pop artist why does someone
become a famous actor because they want
to be liked so as long as the culture
says being liked means having these
opinions then they're going to have
those opinions